also ja kein neues album und das heißt
auch noch mario versus jasko generiert
was ist ist der name programm
ihr dürft euch jetzt nur noch
gegenseitig und dass die anderen außen
vor oder was die anderen rapper sich
nicht trauen und zu dessen hamburger
übernehmen
wie gesagt das sind auch und das ist ja
auch das ja alles spaß und da haben wir
gedacht geben wir den fans man kleinen
einblick wie wir wirklich sind
das wichtigste wird noch mal zeigen dass
wir uns auch über uns selber mal lachen
können unternehmer sondern auch
einstecken können
das heißt ihr lebt wirklich alle
facetten ihrer persönlichkeiten aus und
das eine schließt das andere nicht aus
irgendwo übertreibt man noch ein
bisschen aber so im großen ganzen demo
distanz aus was für chancen bieten sich
studien
ich hab auch schon davon gehört wenn man
ein erfolgreiches rap aber macht mein
studium angeboten immer die professoren
vorne an der bühne und bayern 1 und
kreischen und die bilden darum dass man
neue möglichkeiten weiblich in
weiblicher hinsicht
ich will jetzt mit wohl gern aus und
deswegen sagen einige möglichkeiten
die schlichten sie kauf nehmen bis zum
gilt das bisschen geld reinkommt und ich
spaß daran habe immer so ist dass man
die frauen etwas nächste abkriegt aber
vielleicht ist da die grenze die id
frauen die man abkriegt sind für den
spaß und aber man sucht eine freundin
oder das ist ja eine große großer punkt
trick falsches spiel wie ich sag ich da
noch mal weißt was viel schlimmer ist
schnell in die die frau fürs leben
kennen und das frisst mich innerlich
drama der junge wirklich schwer das ist
unseren kreis du lernst aber das ist
diese nur teilweise selber schuld sobald
eine ernste frau zu mir ankommt versuche
ich das schlecht
ich glaube es liegt ja auch daran wenn
man so eine bestimmt wenn ein viele
leute kennen und die sag mal wenn man
mädel kennenlernt das ist ja sehr
schnell raus was man macht und dann weiß
man ja nicht mehr ist es wirkliche liebe
oder bist du mehr fan was ist das
realisierung der reparieren haben sie
überhaupt schwer oder rapper windeln
oder wie viel gibt kritik gibt's aber
die kriegt immer einen auf die nase ich
weiß nicht ob die irgendwo man den
richtigen hand fertigen
ich habe gehört bevor die überhaupt raus
kam haben die version hamster so ins
loft gesteckt damit die abnimmt
bevor die überhaupt massentaugliches
unternehmen konnte sein sportlicher weiß
wer weiß es auch wieder schön
frauenfeindlich ihr von eurer seite
du musst das mikro geben wird ist also
das habe ich nur gehört zu bekennen wir
uns ja aber das ist es aber wenn ein
mädel rap würzige bist mein ich
respektiere aber wer oder was nennt man
hier mal eine unter ihre fittiche also
ich sag mal eine deutsche rapperin ja
ihr wisst schwester etwas zu sagen nein
wir kennen ja den hintergrund von
schwester erbaut wie soll ich wenn sie
durch musik rausgekommen ist so cool wie
kriegt ihr denn an den spagat hin wenn
er eben doch sehr nachdenklich seit wir
wissen also ich sag dir original was
mein vater sagt mein vater sagt
folgendes du bist 24 wieso machst du das
desto kinderkacke da sagt mein vater
dann sage ich guck mal papa ich mach das
schon länger ich habe spaß daran dass
eine sache die mir in diesem harten
leben ein bisschen spaß bereitete
und sobald das thema zuhause anfängt
musikblogs ab